longtemps jules vallès n'a été considéré
que comme un enragé et son oeuvre
majeure
jacques 20 traces d'abord considéré
comme un pamphlet politique et de fait
ce fils d'instituteur auvergnats néo
puis en 1832 a connu l'existence agité
d'un militant comploteurs contre
napoléon iii seul rédacteur de feuilles
polémique combattants des barricades et
membre de la commune de paris en 1871
il a connu l'exil pendant cinq ans ou
autour duquel il est entré en
littérature
jacques 20 traces c'est jules vallès
trois volumes admirable l'enfant le
bachelier l'insurgé quand vallès les
achève en 1884 la maladie peut avoir
raison de lui et le corbillard des
pauvres l'année d'après l'emportent au
père lachaise
le premier tome l'enfant paraît dans une
très bonne édition de denis labour est
proposée par la collection de poche
folio une lecture recommandée aux
adolescents et parmi tous les autres
ceux qui étudient ici même au lycée
clemenceau de nantes où jules vallès
cuts élèves il y a un siècle et demi à
tous ceux qui creusent vers d'ennuis au
collège où confie pleurer dans la
famille qui pendant leur enfance furent
tyrannisé par leur maître ou rossé par
leurs parents je dédie ce livre
après cette dédicace jules vallès offre
aux jeunesses malheureuse de lumineuses
raison de se battre pour changer la vie